by the way the dudes in our little group
they've been arguing about The Sopranos
ending David Chase every year comes out
gets interviewed and like slips out that
Tony died but he doesn't really say Tony
died it's like a game he's playing with
us right but the best part is listening
to these guys argue about it I love the
ending and think it's brilliant now when
I watched it at the time in real-time I
thought something wrong with my
television I I freaked out like
everybody else and then I sat and I
thought about it and I was like yeah you
know what they kind of telegraphed this
was gonna happen all season and it
happened cool ending how did they
Telegraph all seasons they both ate the
episode before it or two episodes before
it they were talking about what happens
when you die what what do you think
happens and Bobby bacala goes let me
tell you what happens
one second year there then everything
goes to black and it's over I don't know
it just never occurred to me that people
thought he wasn't dead and I find it
funny that like people like Chris and
heiner's don't [ __ ] artists Jason he
just said you watched it you had no idea
what happened and then you had the
Monday Morning Quarterback
to even figure out the story and that's
not what an ending should be JD where do
you stand on this I didn't know I didn't
see anything Telegraph to me I just know
I was like other than not the bread
crumbs out there is completely
irrelevant okay when you're watching the
show I want to know how it ends and I
don't want to make it up again myself
and I don't want to interpret it I want
to know what happens
I listened to your incorrect argument
let me make mine if David Chase wants
Tony Soprano to be dead I want to see at
least 15 bullets in the guy in the diner
sprayed out in front of his family and
them reacting or if he doesn't then show
it doesn't happen but I don't want to be
looking to see if my cable is connected
because it goes to black and I'm unsure
if you were reading a book and there was
no ending in other words the book just
ended and it didn't have blank
maybe the context of the type of book or
story you're reading with this I mean I
get anything seasoned artsy-fartsy did
you see the amount of violence that was
on this show and what happened and how
different what
how people act and about attorney than
the ending he will on the journey it was
the end of the journey okay
don't stop believing this playing it's
building up to this great moment and
then okay how are we gonna end this
thing oh it's up to you to interpret it
[ __ ] no it's not wait a minute guys if
they come in getting sucked into this
Rob this question for me they start
spraying bullets right he's there with
his entire family that's right
dude they all die well that's what I
want to know you're agreeing with John
you need to see the ending I don't know
what happened because right I never saw
anything mommy you want to weigh in on
this I just have to correct Jason he
read the first sentence of the article
but not the second can I just read this
this section this is the problem I
always say in the back office people
read the headlines think your article
right now I'm looking at the article
right now go ahead this is the Reuters
article so yes this they're quoting
Bobby bacala saying at the end you
probably don't hear anything everything
just goes black which is why he says
while they said fish graph one briefly
in a flashback now you look at a
different article brother hear him the
very next sentence one rather large
problem baccala never says anything
about it all going to black the exchange
is you probably don't hear it when it
happens
that's it you're reading something
different I'm read here you won't have
from router's Reuters what the [ __ ] you
say Reuters at the end you probably
don't hear anything everything just goes
black Bobby says while they sit fishing
in a small boat in the lake so I think
it's the most the latest information old
article that they didn't correct and we
should just look at these things more
carefully that's all I met just sent me
his source article it is not it is it is
a letter to the editor saying to the
that's man do you know what an ombudsman
this is this is what I was trying to
tell you it's going on you guys got to
get out of quarantine that's what I'm
[Music]